c'est pas le carburant
et pour le carburant mettez vous sur
cette pub là j'ai décale de la
frictionnaire bloque le passage j'ai eu
son gars ils peuvent pas sortir mais toi
il pense que je travaille ici non non
ils savent on leur a vertu pour leur
donner un coup de main regardez
maintenant les mamie elles peuvent
traverser tranquillement
allez-y mesdames donc je vais mettre de
l'éthanol je peux mettre la balle moi tu
te mets juste comme ça juste là de ce
côté là
des fois il y a des femmes il y a quatre
chips ils arrivent dans une voiture et
il passe devant un peu rien faire tu
vois alors que si ça serait des mecs
dans la voiture ils auraient pas fait la
même chose ça veut dire nous on est là
pour la bienveillance que tout le monde
mette son carburant tranquillement et il
y a des fils aussi par exemple là-bas
ils vont attendre deux heures là-bas 3h
parce que je vais doubler passeport là
c'est dur on fait passer les voitures 2
par 2 comme ça tout le monde a le même
temps d'attente après généralement le
temps d'attendre c'est quoi ces 20
minutes sinon ça me fait des 1h 2h 3h
mais normalement
venez venez on va vous faire avancer
fais l'avancer des rendez-vous
faut lui faire un passage
du tout mais top c'est génial ce qui
nous en fait j'ai dit heureusement
qu'ils sont là c'est superbe franchement
c'est magnifique moi aussi je suis à
côté j'ai mon dépôt c'est super voilà
franchement bonne organisation la cité
magnifique voilà top mais rien à dire
tout à l'heure
c'est bon ça passe ça passe super bien
la dernière fois ça se disputer on a
géré plus d'histoires plus de bagarre
c'était vide elle avait encore perdu
tout le monde est au courant qu'ils
doivent qui qui passe de par deux tout
le monde est au courant qu'il y a voilà
que il y a des gens qui gère ici ça veut
dire ils attendent en fait leur tour
c'est juste le petit problème
pour pour les habitants du quartier et
pour les gens on voit que la première
fois qu'on l'a fait ils ont apprécié il
était content qu'on soit là ils nous ont
beaucoup remercié et voilà ça vous a
fait plaisir en fait nous ça nous fait
plaisir d'aider les gens et voilà et
vous faites ça depuis combien de temps
ça fait trois jours
non si vous voulez sortir
[Musique]
qui se mobilise là il y a tout le monde
il y a les jeunes il y a les plus âgés
tout le monde est là
on est des meilleurs donnés
ils font passer les gens sans bagarre
sans rien
moi c'est bien ce que vous faites merci
moi du tout
[Musique]
non franchement c'est une super
initiative c'est super sympa c'est super
gentil c'est ordonné et tout nickel
problème aucun problème
des bonbons ils veulent encore plus me
tuer